[Musique]
combien trouve ton espèce d'écrevisses
en amérique du nord
il y en a près de 400 ce qui correspond
environ au trois quart de toutes les
espèces connues dans le monde
ces petites bêtes sont présentes sur
tous les continents sauf en afrique et
en antarctique au québec qu'on en a
répertorié jusqu'à maintenant huit
espèces
on les retrouve dans différents plans
d'eau les petits ruisseaux jusqu'au
fleuve saint-laurent cinq espèces sont
indigènes soient l'écrevisse de
ruisseaux les crever sarrauste karenni
l'écrevisse marbre et l'écrevisse à
epping et l'écrevisse à pattes bleues
trois ont été introduites sur le
territoire il s'agit des écrevisses
géante obscur et à taches rouges
si les écrevisses ressemble un peu aux
marées aux craintes c'est que tous les
trois sont des invertébrés qui
appartiennent à la grande place des
crustacés
tout comme ses petits cousins les
écrevisses gèlèdé capone c'est à dire
qu'elles ont dit
elles sont aussi dotés d'un exosquelette
un squelette externe qu'elle volontaire
au moment de l'année et qui se reforment
ans
elles peuvent même régénérer une fat
wind peines perdues d'un combat les
écrevisses vivent dans nos bus et sont
surtout actives la nuit elles se
reproduisent à l'automne et durant
l'hiver elle fonctionne au ralenti
source de nourriture pour de nombreux
animaux comme les poissons les
amphibiens ou les oiseaux les écrevisses
fonte un maillon important de la chaîne
alimentaire
[Musique]